depuis leur confinement loïc est de
retour à voisins le bretonneux cet
étudiant en deuxième année de prépa
ingénieurs à caen est revenu chez ses
parents il suit ses cours à distance
depuis le 30 octobre dernier
mon emploi du temps il est maintenu en
fait j'ai exactement les mêmes emplois
du temps que si j'étais en présentiel
donc je kouba mes journées vont être un
peu pareil quand je vais avoir des
heures de trous je vais travailler mais
td de mon côté c'est vraiment un même
type de journée que je pouvais avoir
avant une organisation que le jeune
homme de 19 ans espère provisoire il
compte reprendre les cours en présentiel
dans les prochains mois là tout seul
devant son écran c'est dur de rester
concentré surtout quand des fois on a
par la matinée on a trois heures et
demie du courant visiofoot juste devant
son écran écouter le prof dans le
bâtiment de droit de l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines les
3000 étudiants ne sont pas présent non
plus sur site depuis le confinement
la plupart des enseignants donnent des
cours en télétravail d'autres préfèrent
l'atmosphère d'un amphithéâtre même vide
c'est le cas de ce professeur il donne
un cours à huis clos une première dans
sa carrière débutée en 1976 ça peut
faire un peu un petit peu étrange dans
les premières secondes
mais très vite tout de suite là la
mécanique habituelle reprend et je parle
à la salle comme si mes étudiants et
était là ça ne me change pas
pas grand chose en réalité et j'espère
surtout que pour eux ça ne change pas
trop de choses non plus car ils sont à
l'autre bout de de la caméra aujourd'hui
350 élèves suivront ce cours de 3h à
distance ça peut être tout à fait
nouveau et intéressant comme complément
est-ce que ça doit remplacer la présence
physique
je n'en suis pas persuadé et
personnellement je reste attaché au
cours corps présents comme on dirait
devant une juridiction à cause de
l'interactivité les universités ne
rouvriront pas avant minimum trois
semaines la date du déconfinement est
pour l'instant fixée au 1er décembre